[Music]
[Applause]
in blandino Fox NFL rules analyst and
former vice president of officiating for
the NFL he was part of Fox's Super Bowl
pregame show he joins us on the program
Dean thanks for getting up uh if I gave
you a great or you uh you were going to
give me a grade for the first 59 minutes
of officiating in the last minute of the
Super Bowl would those grades be the
same for the officials
I think they would I I thought overall
the the game they officiated a good game
for the most part I think the calls were
right
um but obviously when you have a call
like that at the end of a game that's
going to be controversial there there's
it felt like we were robbed of a a
classic finish right and I think that's
what I think that's what people are
upset about is you know throw the flag
in that situation we go from the Chiefs
most likely kicking the go-ahead field
goal and then Jalen hurts and the Eagles
getting the ball back instead we got two
kneel Downs running out the clock a
field goal and I think that's part of
the debate today is do you throw the
flag in that situation would you
I to me it's it's hard to sit there and
watch James Bradberry grab the jersey
and say that's not a foul I mean there's
no way I can sit here and say it's not a
foul for holding and uh and if it's a
foul in the first quarter it has to be a
foul in the fourth quarter you want to
be consistent you don't want your
officials to be officiating the the
situation they have to they have to
compartmentalize and say okay I'm gonna
officiate this play and if there's a
foul I have to call it but again I think
we we just we all felt myself included
as a fan is if I'm wondering if he
doesn't throw the flag in that situation
are we even talking about that play it's
one of probably not but when you watch
the replay and you see the Jersey grab
that by rule is a foul
players just want consistency and there
were no holding calls prior to that in
the first 59 minutes and then all of a
sudden you have one there if it's true
you can call holding on every call then
how do you arbitrate that how do you go
no that's a whole that's sort of no I'm
not going to call that explain that to
me that's the biggest challenge you know
there was a player earlier it might have
been Kansas City's first or second drive
on third down where where it looked like
the the Eagles got away with a with a
hold a pass interference
um and I'm sure you could go back and
see similar actions throughout the game
and I'm sure that's you know that's what
people are doing right now
um biggest challenge in officiating it's
that consistency piece that that If
You're Gonna Let It Go the whole game
you can't throw the flag in a critical
situation
um you want to be officiating the same
standard the entire game and I haven't
gone through the the entire coaching
tape and looked at every play yet
um and if there were a bunch of holes
that were missed then then yeah then why
are we calling that one at the end and
not calling those others because that's
what we all want consistency explain to
me having All-Star Crews as opposed to
honoring just a great crew during the
regular season
yeah this has been a debate and we've
gone back and forth my time at the
officiating Department my colleague at
Fox Sports Mike Pereira and and the crew
I like the cohesion of the crew I like
the crew working together the
communication is is is better if you and
I work together all year we're going to
know what each other's thinking and
we're not going to have to kind of learn
there's the learning curve is is not as
steep uh but there's something to be
said for having your best officials in
your in your toughest and most important
games I still think there's a balance I
think you need that crew continuity I
think whenever you can keep the crews
intact there's a grading system an
evaluation system they're put into tears
this is something that's negotiated with
the NFL referees Association they want
the the individual based system in the
postseason and that was negotiated in
the CBA so the league is kind of their
hands are tied on this but again you do
have some flexibility in in taking your
top rated officials but keeping the
crews together
um whenever possible
do we is there anybody that gets
together with the officials prior to the
playoffs or prior to a Super Bowl and
say let's not make the game about us
let's fewer calls is that message sent
well I wouldn't say the message of fewer
calls is sent but I think that the
general philosophy
as long as I've been involved and I know
it it predates me is that officiating is
not to be the story right we we don't
want to interject ourselves into the
game we don't want to be overly
technical but you have to throw Flags
when when they're there and there's this
this misconception of we're going to let
the players decide the game and and
people tend to think okay that means
don't throw Flags but if you don't throw
Flags then inevitably teams pick up on
that they're going to get aggressive
especially in in the secondary with with
defensive holding and things like that
and they're going to gain an unfair
Advantage I mean that that's why that's
why we have you know uh speeding tickets
you know on highways and if there was no
no fear of getting a speeding ticket
we'd all be dry out maybe I'm speaking
for myself I know I'd be driving 100
miles an hour but it's just one of those
things that you never want the
officiating to be the story but never in
my time has anyone said hey we're not
going to throw Flags today we're going
to let them play because you allow a
team to gain an advantage when you do do
that when you when you go into a game
like that have you ever gone to a Super
Bowl party with a group of people and
they find out what you used to do yes
yes how annoying party any party how how
annoying is that
I you know I love talking about football
but especially now when we've gone
through I can't think how many weeks and
months like I'm on the plane ride home
if somebody hey what do you do I'm just
the one picking I'm an accountant and
you know I'm just I'm something that has
nothing to do with football
Dean thanks for getting up with us we
appreciate uh your explanations there
you got it that's uh Dean blandino Fox
NFL rules analyst he was part of uh
Fox's Super Bowl pregame show